fifteen years ago Facebook didn't exist
today it dominates our lives shapes our
conversation even to some extent
determines the way we think Americans
spend close to an hour every single day
on Facebook but the company wants more
Facebook is rolling out a new app
messenger for kids it's aimed at
children as young as six more than a
hundred child development experts have
warned that this is a bad idea it could
be a disaster it serves to a dict kids
to social media earlier than ever it is
massive implications for our society the
company seems to be ignoring that Jim
Steyer CEO of common sense and wrote the
book talking back to Facebook and he
joins us tonight Jim thanks for coming
on so great if I mischaracterized what
this app is intended to do and who it's
aimed at nope I think you nailed it
Tucker I mean really this is about
social media for the kindergarten set
it's basically getting hooked kids you
know at younger and younger ages 6 7 8
on social media platforms like Facebook
and it's crazy we don't need it and
that's why all the experts came out and
suggested that but we know that heavy
social media use among young people
leads to social maladjustment depression
may be even more grave things I mean the
implication is certainly that it can
really hurt people gravely hurt them
that's right why would Facebook want to
do it because it's in their own economic
best interest I mean truthfully you're
trying to hook people at younger and
younger ages to the brand and to the
concept and so it's an economic
incentive but obviously it's missing out
on all the negative unintended
consequences that you just referred to I
mean this is just a no-brainer for a
parent why would you want your
six-year-old using Facebook or Instagram
so this is just should be a non-starter
for parents I mean I'm sure RJ Reynolds
would like to come out with a new
cigarette this kindergarten friendly but
we say no you can't I mean adults can
decide to do that if they want but our
society does not allow it right
cigarette makers to sell to children why
are we allowing Facebook to do this when
we know it harms them well I think
that's a very apt comparison and it's
like you know candy coated cigarettes so
you want to hook kids at younger and
younger ages so we actually at common
sense to think this is not a good idea
at all and you know it also brings up
the broader
how do you get your kids you're a parent
to Tucker you know how do you get your
kids away from the screen enjoying the
incredible outdoors and world around
them you just don't want them sitting on
social media platforms in kindergarten
or actually at any age yeah I mean we
know that it affects kids ability to
read and retain information and to think
clearly so is there any legislative
effort to pull back or we just passive
in the face of the threat to our
children no no actually you know Tucker
there's a lot of good stuff coming on
this kind of issue there stuff here on
the west coast in terms of looking at
the addiction research that needs to be
done around social media platforms
you're seeing much greater privacy
concern now you're seeing a number of
different legislative efforts to try to
incur encourage or require companies to
respect the young kids in their audience
and that's gonna grow we passed a bill
called the eraser button yeah here in
California a couple of years ago so that
kids who made dumb decisions could erase
them so I think you're gonna see a
growing public outcry and I think why
you you're covering it helps than that
as well I hope so I mean I can just see
the mark I sure will maps to babies to
learn how to crawl we're losing a lot in
this and Jim thank you for setting a
call about it
I appreciate you yeah well thank you for
having us on Tucker and thanks for your
supporting it as well we like it
always